it isn't rare for a country to seize the
land of another and it's not rare for
the great powers to be involved in this
process in some form or another what is
rare is that the country having its land
taken isn't at war or even invited to
the discussions concerning it this is
what happened to czechoslovakia in 1938
when the german government demanded the
sudetenland for its own it was ceded to
germany after britain france and italy
held a conference with the germans and
agreed to the transfer the czechs were
not invited yet in the end still handed
the land over which raises the question
why did they go along with it so as of
1938 europe was a pretty tense place
countries like germany italy and hungary
were fairly open about claiming the
lands of their neighbours austria had
just been unified with germany and
britain and france were concerned that
this irredentism was going to lead to
another major war which neither of them
wanted because dying is terrible as such
when the german government demanded that
these lands the sudetenland and its
large german population be handed over
the czechs didn't want to because this
region was very mountainous and they'd
spent a bunch of money building defenses
there to defend them from a german
attack they were also bolstered by
france and the soviet union having
previously pledged to defend them
although there was one major problem
with these alliances they weren't worth
anything france had promised to protect
czechoslovakia but actually fulfilling
that guarantee sounded difficult and war
was scary so they were lukewarm on the
idea as for the ussr they didn't share a
border with czechoslovakia meaning
they'd have to go through either poland
or romania neither of which were ever
going to let that happen as such the
government in prague turned to britain
for help and britain's response was well
germany sort of has a point the czechs
didn't want to back down and thus it
seemed that war was inevitable britain
and france didn't want this and so it
was time for a conference with italy's
moderation the allies agreed to hand
germany everything that had asked for so
long as it agreed not to conquer
czechoslovakia soon afterwards for
france this gave them an out since if
the czechs refused they could say that
they were provoking germany and doing
nothing to uphold peace as such the
czechs who were pretty upset about all
of this were on their own thus they had
no choice but to yield the territory
since they knew that they couldn't
defeat germany on their own something
made much more difficult considering
that whilst the munich conference was
ongoing the polish had marched into the
country and taken some land for itself
so with that the czechs handed over the
sudetenland which meant that things were
settled them right well no sensing
weakness hungary opted to settle some
territorial grudges of its own its
government wanted these lands and the
hungarians that lived there which of
course meant that it was time for
another conference this time britain and
france weren't invited and shockingly
yet again it was decided that
czechoslovakia would lose territory so
why didn't they resist this time well
they were now in an even weaker position
than before their best defense against a
german attack was now gone their allies
had completely abandoned them and the
government's primary concern was to not
die it was hoped though that these
embarrassing concessions would preserve
peace and at least maintain
czechoslovakia's independence but fun
fact no in 1939 with german backing
slovakia declared its independence
hungary was then given more territory
and the czech state was promptly
occupied by german troops and turned
into a protectorate again they weren't
able to resist because much of their
defense's industry and the majority of
their population had just been taken
away from them as such czechoslovakia
ceased to exist and it wouldn't return
until after world war ii was over and it
was hoped in the new czechoslovakian
government that their allies would have
learned from these mistakes and wouldn't
sell them out again well good luck with
that i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with a special
thanks to my patrons james bissonette
kelly money maker corso wolfe jordan
longley adam stalter jerry landon marcus
asner wyan hockey spencer lightfoot
words about books podcast gustav swan
captain cydog rod d martin common yoon
boogery wiggily mrs it marvin cassow
aaron the white matthew shipley alex
schwinn maggie patzkowski anthony
beckett maxon flaudio the mcwhopper
corey turner spinning three plates
copper tone winston k wood charles the
first and scottish trekkie